Next up, Kevin and Nischelle,
we're gonna talk about best actor.
I mean,
this one I think,
we're all gonna be united on.
Yeah,
Absolutely.
Right?
Like, one, two, three,
Yeah,
say the name.
Will Smith.
Yep, there you go,
Will Smith
Will Smith,
yeah,
I'm sorry.
No, it's true.
(Ross chuckles)
Well, he's won everything,
it really feels like it's time,
but do you remember last year,
we all predicted Chadwick Boseman was gonna win?
He won everything and then Anthony Hopkins
upset in the end.
So, it's not in the bag yet,
but I would be really shocked
if Will Smith didn't walk home with an Oscar.
I am just gonna be furious.
(Ross chuckles)
It's his time.
I mean, this is him at his best,
it deserves an award.
Totally.
And I love the arc of Will Smith's career,
I mean, think about it,
We got to know him as like a music artist,
and then The Fresh Prince of Bel-Air,
and then this like action star,
and to be turning in this kind of work now,
you never put Will Smith in a box,
and I love
that he's doing this.
I know,
it's true.
I love range, it's so sexy.
Absolutely.
Well--
But he is up against
some heavyweights, guys,
O gosh.
I mean, he's up against Denzel Washington,
who is nominated for Macbeth,
he is the most
(audience applauding)
nominated black actor
of all time.
(audience applauding)
Which is a really amazing fact,
I loved hearing that.
It didn't surprise me,
but again, these are the kind of facts
that I think are so interesting.
And so--
Can I just shout out
Andrew Garfield too in Tick, Tick... Boom?
Did you guys see this
on Netflix?
Please do.
(audience applauding)
He put so much of himself
He was
in that--
spectacular
in Tick, Tick... Boom
Yeah.
(audience applauding)
And our audience
actually voted for him
to win this year.
Wow!
Oh wow!
With a 43%.
Wow.
Wow, audience!
You see, that's something to think about,
because he was so good.
I mean, I came in the next day after seeing this
and I said,
"Oh my God, Nischelle."
Yeah, yeah.
If there's someone that I feel
could upset Will Smith,
it would be Andrew Garfield
Yeah.
in this category.
I definitely think so,
but the audience,
man!
Bucking the trend.
I know.
Rossy, talk about best actress,
Well--
'cause I have
a real opinion here
You do?
I do!
Me too,
me too.
This is the category
everybody is watching,
it is so up in the air,
nobody knows for sure,
let's take a look at the nominees.
Nicole Kidman won the Golden Globe,
Jessica Chastain won the SAG,
and the experts have no idea
who's gonna win this,
so, Drew, who do you think it's gonna be?
Nischelle, I'm gonna count to three,
and we'll say the name
Okay.
at the same time.
Okay, all right.
One,
two, three,
Jessica.
Jessica Chastain.
Jessica Chastain, yeah.
Yeah.
(Nischelle chuckles)
(audience applauding)
That's who I'm rooting for.
100%
(audience applauding)
Same, same.
I loved this movie.
She's just also been such a force
for so many years,
Yeah.
she's what they call a scene-stealer,
it doesn't matter the role,
the size,
she just captivates you.
I know this project was very personal
for her,
Very, to her,
yeah.
When she got the rights to this,
she really wanted to tell the story
that Tammy Faye,
while she was--
In terms of a Christian conservative,
she was also very compassionate,
she was inclusive,
(Drew sighs)
she also reached out to the LGBTQ+ community,
and wanted to make sure they felt loved
and heard,
and so, when she got to do this,
it meant everything to her.
Yeah.
Because it very easily
could have been a caricature
Yeah.
of a Tammy Faye,
So many people
did caricatures of her.
Right.
To celebrate a woman
who just against all odds kept saying,
can't we love people for who they really are?
(Drew mimics sobbing)
I'm like,
oh my God!
Exactly.
I agree with you,
Tammy Faye.
(Ross chuckles)
Yeah.
Can't we just love people
(audience applauding)
for who they are?
Yeah.
(audience applauding)
And Jessica just embodies them.
Yeah, she did such a great--
Okay, let's check our viewer poll,
what did they say?
All right,
let's take a look.
Okay.
Rossy, tell.
Ooh, Kristen Stewart
for Spencer?
That's your Princess Diana
fascination
Yeah.
You know, and--
That's what that is.
Kristin Stewart had been snubbed
for a couple of other awards,
she wasn't nominated for,
so, there was questioned whether or not
she'd be nominated at all.
She could win,
I'm telling you,
this is the race that is wide open.
All right,
we're gonna move to best director.
Nischelle, Kevin, who's taking it home?
Again, head and heart here for me,
my heart is with Steven Spielberg,
my head says Jane Campion,
I'm rooting for Steven,
but Jane Campion's kind of been
the award season's darling too,
and in '93, she became only the second woman
to be nominated for best director,
that was for The Piano,
the first was Lina Wertmuller in '78
for Seven Beauties,
and if she were to win for Power of the Dog,
and you add that to Chloe Zhao last year,
that's the first females
to ever win back-to-back best director,
which I think is phenomenal.
And The Power of the Dog
is such a beautiful--
It's a director's film.
That's what it is,
and I think that for The Academy,
it is folks who look at that.
It's a director's film.
But Steven Spielberg is the man,
he's the king of movies,
and if he wins for West Side Story,
he would join the esteemed group of directors
with eight--
Well, he has eight total nods
right now.
Yeah.
Martin Scorsese,
Billy Wilder,
(Nischelle sighs)
William Wyler.
Spielberg can also,
he's already won twice
for Schindler's List and Saving Private Ryan,
so, this will be his third Oscar,
and that would be an esteemed list
of directors of what?
Three times.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
For sure.
Well, let's see
who the viewers picked.
What is it?
Mmm,
yes, Nischelle!
Aah,
Steven Spielberg.
Come on, Steven Spielberg,
Let's go.
(audience applauding)
I do love that people are so outspoken
about women winning in this category,
so, if Jane Campion wins,
that's fantastic.
Chloe Zhao last year,
Natalie Portman came out with the dress
with all the women's names
Oh yeah.
who weren't nominated.
Yes.
So,
advocacy works
and we should all keep our voices heard
and--
And Drew,
Drew, it's very important
that women are getting the opportunities
to direct these big movies,
these good movies,
a diversity of directors
makes a diversity of great films,
and I think
Absolutely.
that is so important.
Absolutely,
I agree.
(upbeat music)
(upbeat music fades)